In a recent survey,
a majority of respondents
picked their sense of smell
as the one they'd be
most willing to give up
among the traditional five senses.
But if you love food,
you should be giving your nose
much more credit.
Because it’s actually our sense of smell
that plays a huge role
in our ability to process flavor.
[Body Stuff with Dr. Jen Gunter]
First, let's talk about how smell works,
from coffee to stinky trash.
The substances around us
give off volatiles,
which you can think of
as tiny smell molecules.
We breathe in these smell molecules,
which then stimulate
the olfactory sensory neurons
that sit high in the nose.
Each of these neurons contains
an odor receptor on its surface.
Once the odor receptors are triggered
by these smell molecules,
the neurons send information
about them to the brain.
Here's what I think is so cool.
The brain not only categorizes
that information as a particular odor,
it may also begin to associate feelings,
like pleasure or disgust and other moods
and emotions with that odor
for future reference.
For example, you sniff bacon, you eat it,
your taste buds get salt,
and then your body gets a whack of fat,
which is an energy source.
So the brain loves it
and attaches a positive label to it.
The next time you smell bacon,
a sensation associated
with pleasure arises.
Now, there are a lot of smells out there,
more than our 400 or so
odor receptors can detect.
But people with a healthy
working sense of smell
have odor receptors that can combine
to detect anywhere between 10,000
to more than a trillion different odors.
Now, taste is completely different.
It comes from taste receptors
on our tongues and in our mouths.
Taste is limited to the basics:
salty, sweet, bitter, sour
and, somewhat controversially,
umami or savory.
You can taste without smell,
but anyone with a stuffy nose can attest
that's a pretty bland experience.
That's because when we eat,
for example, chewing pizza,
the pizza releases volatiles
that travel from our mouths and throat
up through the nasal passage.
There, olfactory neurons get
all the complex smells from the pizza
and send that information to the brain.
The smell and taste work together
to help us enjoy food.
When our nose isn't working properly
and food seems flavorless,
it's because we're only tasting
those basic tastes
without any of the complex odors
detected through smell.
So the next time you savor
an amazing flavor,
thank your nose.
Our sense of smell is what brings
nuance to what we eat.